good afternoon everyone welcome to
cabinets so it's 3:30 and now we start
so without further ado apologies for
absence receive from councillor
Pemberton and councillor Cargill
disclosures of interest I'm a member of
Stratford Town Council I've also done
work on the neighbourhood plan so on
item five I will not be chairing the
meeting for that item that acceptable
good right and chairman I'd like to
declare an interest and write him seven
because I reside in the Tysoe Parish
Council area Thank You mr. Grafton item
three minutes so looking at the minute
from the meeting on the 10th of
September I believe that there was a
change to the minutes proposed by on
item 2 9 for disposal of the Grange
Selden and that comes from OS say-so
councillor Barker would you prefer to
you should have in front of you where
the recommendation from OSC is that the
minute 294 etc be amended to reflect the
preamble above I hope you don't want me
to read the whole preamble because that
was a very long meeting to produce that
preamble let's not go any further and it
was turned to include a definition of
curtilage in relation to the Grange this
definition should make clear the
curtilage sould be restricted to land
necessary to provide suitable access i'm
india parking hopefully that is
acceptable so the minutes should be
revised to take account of the
recommendation from overview and
scrutiny Thank You councillor Barca
council organ yes and for the avoid
any doubt on on the minute that's going
to come out that it does the the minute
here from and that the head of technical
up to the final details of self remains
in following the revised bit to go in
you should really have a proposer and
seconder and then have it approved Alden
yes thank you chairman I'm happy to
propose the amendments an arm up into
second it
can I have people's approval for that
you see and that's an approval thank you
very much so that's approved to alter
the minutes so moving on to item four
ships turn on Steaua Neighborhood
Development Plan in the absence of
councillor Pemberton I will take this
issue and it ease I mean basically this
is routine in that the ships turn on
stellar neighborhood development plan
was endorsed by more than the required
threshold in the referendum of six of
September the council must now adopt the
NDP and thereby making part of the
development plan the stratford-on-avon
district and the council has no
discretion at this stage so once it goes
to council basic it has to go to council
so the recommendation on page eleven
that ships non-sterile neighborhood
development plan the pen is adopted with
immediate effect with the consequence
that it becomes part of the development
plan for stratford-on-avon district all
those in favor thank you
so moving on to item five and if I hand
over to Morris for this item please
Thank You leader yes this item comes
before you
this report is alongside the
modifications recommended by the
examiner provides for the basis for the
district cats or to decide what action
to take in response to each of the
examiner's modifications it will enable
the cabinet to consider recommending
that the stratford-upon-avon David what
development plan precedes to recommend
referendum on the basis that as modified
it will meet the basic conditions
statement you will be pleased to know
that you're not expected to get a copy
and read or what I can say is that the
decision statement has been produced by
John cafard it has been looked at
carefully by the portfolio holder and I
would urge you to look at page 19 item 4
members comments cancer Darren
Pemberton's portfolio holder says the
Town Council has worked positively with
the District Council on the
neighbourhood plan and have taken the
examiner's proposed modifications on
board it is entirely appropriate for the
plan to now move forward to referendum
so this is really a basic item and the
recommendations are unless anybody has
got any questions which I'm really
unqualified to answer at this moment
because I hadn't had the jobs to read so
no questions so the recommendations are
one that the recommended modifications
has set out in the decision statement
that's this appendix wanted this report
be received and endorsed that the
stratford-upon-avon neighborhood
development plan as modified be endorsed
as meeting the basic conditions and all
other requirements and thus should now
proceed to referendum can I take it that
you are going to approve that thank you
leader back to you q councillor house
item 6 is the harbour e and death
Brigade development plan once again in
the absence of councillor Pemberton I
will take this and
at this point it's the modifications be
received and endorsed and they should
proceed to referendum looking at the
conclusion it's considered the
modification suggested by the examiner
together with the addition of other
minor variations subsequently agreed
between the LPR in qualifying body mates
the basic conditions are such the NDP
should proceed to referendum is modified
it is recommended the Cabinet resolves
to approve these modifications and
recommendations so is there any
discussion any questions any debate
counselor thank you now I was going to
say is I've monitored this going through
the whole process and the work that
Harbury and dep is have had we strap the
district council and i'd like to commend
them and thank them because it's been a
lot of hard work it's been a long time
and I'm pleased that we're going towards
the referendum thank you to Council
Harris councillor kettle as neighbor and
board member and former warden for
Harvard congratulation to hopper having
gotten so far just one point of
clarification mr. chairman and that is
making queries of our a of better
position to neighborhood plans progress
I was informed that there had been a
slight change because of boundary
changes which had a no material impact
with the water procedural change just to
ensure that that was reflective
neighborhood develop plan was not
actually I couldn't find it attach this
document probably one for mr. careful
mr. carefully wish to comment fine Thank
You mr. careful being taken account of
without any further comments so in that
case can we move to the recommendations
on page 23 that they recommended
modifications are set out in the
decision statement appendix three to
this report be received an endorsed
another Harbury and DEP Asst bridge de
Burgh development plan as modified they
endorsed as meeting the basic ambitions
and all other requirements and there
should now proceed to referendum can I
have your agreement members of cabinet
thank you moving on now to item 7 which
is the tie so Neighborhood Development
Plan and we have some speakers on the
Tison neighborhood development plan so
we have David Roche and councillor
Jacqui Sinclair
David rotis chair of the Tyson
neighborhood planning group and Jackie
Sinclair is Tysoe parish council would
you like to come forward to the
microphone please
yes I I believe they tell me what I
believe that only one of you is going to
speak and you have two and a half
minutes so if you would please use the
microphone thank you I'd like to thank
the officers for their large leave
constructive comments on the draft plan
it is gratifying after spending many
hundreds of hours drafting the document
that the comments the officers have made
contain no deal-breakers that would
cause us to go back to drawing the board
in a significant way the Parish Council
the neighbourhood plan group believed
that there is support from the majority
of Tysoe residents for the planners
drafted there have been of course
objections from small groups on narrow
self-interested topics and questions
about the process we have followed and
the transparency of that process we had
been advised by Neo peers throughout and
have no reason to believe that we have
not been other than fully inclusive in
our consultations as evidenced by the
enormous response on our previous draft
plan in 2017 and a full response to this
current draft having said that I'd like
to clarify two areas that the offices
commented on the first relates to the
comments regarding the beer work we are
proposing around there at ISO the
implication that the Buick has been
drawn in such a way to include large
swathes of non-residential land this is
not so the dwellings in lower Tysoe are
somewhat different from the majority in
the rest of the village in that most of
the large houses built on large plots
which are well spaced out the bureau
Arby's drawn as tightly as reasonably
possible and all of the land encompasses
is domestic garden of course we will go
back to see if we can tighten the
boundary in any way but we felt it would
dispel the implication that the Bureau
has endorsed large tracts of otherwise
non developed land our second area
clarification is the village design
statement there are comments that imply
that it is too prescriptive it may well
be more prescriptive than found in other
neighborhood plans but that is for a
very good reason
Tyrese
suffered what we can only refer to as a
planning Fiasco warehouses of
unacceptable design were allowed to be
built on the wrong but it out of the
wrong material are one of the most
sensitive sites in the village this
whisper resulted in a public outcry and
an apology being made by the portfolio
holder the Parish Council in the
neighbourhood plan group want to do
everything they possibly can to prevent
such a disaster happening again these do
topic those two topics aside who will
take your constructive comments on board
alongside over 120 comments we have
received from residents when we draft
our submission plan in due course
finally I'd like to thank the officers
on behalf of the parish council and the
neighbourhood plan Barry for their
patience in the face of many comments
and concerns raised by residents and for
their sound advice which has not wavered
over many months during which the plan
has been in production thank you for
your attention David wrote the chairman
of the neighbourhood plan group and I
are happy to answer any questions you
may have thank you are there any
questions now in that case Thank You
councillor Sinclair and mr. Roche but
now we have dr. rosemary Collier and mr.
Keith risk and again two and a half
minutes although I will allow a little
leeway so whenever you're ready if you
would like to start okay so I'm speaking
for myself and 18 are the residents of
lower ty so named in my letter to you
who are aware of what I'm going to say
we conclude that the draft plan for ty
so fails the statutory Basic Conditions
it must meet before it proceeds to
referendum we ask that it should not
proceed in its current form to
submission version until these failings
have been remedied our reasons for
coming to this conclusion include the
draft plan proposes to include lower ty
so in the local service village of ty so
lower ty so is a dist
to rural hamlet separate from the local
service village of Tyson it does not
have any services it is at a distance of
more than 800 meters from the services
of the local service village with no
public transport residents rely on the
car for access to services and
employment
Stratford's core strategy policies
support the assessment that lower Tysoe
is an unsustainable location for housing
development the draft plan seeks to
overturn this assessment the drafts
proposed built-up area boundary for the
local service village of theis though is
so tightly drawn that it would not
permit meaningful development creating a
built-up area boundary for lower ty so
to compensate for the failure to
identify sites for housing development
in the local service village would
fundamentally and unacceptably change
lower Saito's planning status removing
the general presumption against
development there have been failures of
due process in the preparation of the
plan there is no valid evidence that
lower Tysoe residents or residents the
parish have approved the drafts proposal
for lower Tysoe
information and explanations about this
and other plan policy matters have been
withheld from a misrepresented to
residents and stakeholders preventing
meaningful comment on the draft
Stratford planning policy offices have
repeatedly confirmed lower ties those
distinct planning status in conformity
with planning policies CS 1 CS 15 and a
s 10 if these strategic policies are not
adhere to it would create an
unacceptable precedent for the location
of housing development in the Stratford
area exceptions such as inclines and and
little countin should not become a norm
in how these policies are applied thank
you for listening
any questions any comments from members
of cabinet No in that case thank you dr.
Thalia and Thank You mr. risk
so props I should just clarify something
about the actual NDP process we are
currently what he's known as a
regulation 14 position which is
pre-submission publicity the cabinets
are asked to agree
SDC comments as laid out in the paper in
item seven this is our response to the
consultation these are our comments the
reality actually is the issues that have
been raised are actually as it says in
the neighborhood development plan page
twenty four point four ten six in the
spirit of localism it is entirely up to
the residents of the parish to decide
where the lower ty cell should be
included in the tie so local service
village with its own built-up area
boundary this is at this stage an issue
for the parish council in terms of the
Neighborhood Development Plan and I
think at that point it is really over to
tie so parish council on the
neighborhood planning team to explore
those issues and come to a resolution as
far as we're concerned today we have to
agree that the shed you love comments
are in appendix one that item seven is
endorsed and submitted to the Parish
Council is a formal response to the pre
submission consultation process
associated with the draft I so narrowed
development plan provided at appendix 2
any discussion or comments or questions
from members of cabinet counselor kettle
in the event that the neighborhood
wonder plan map was adopted by the
council would that mean that the be way
beef attire would be adjusted to me to
match that of my understanding would be
perhaps mr. Clair furred could comment
on the accuracy of this there are stages
to go through and those stages include
independent examination so if the
neighborhood development plan with the
boundaries went through independent
examination and then went through
referendum then I would assume the
neighborhood development plan with those
built-up area boundaries would be
approved I see any further questions or
comments in that case members of council
sorry members of cabinet looking at the
recommendation on page 29 does this have
your approval
great thank you so moving on now to
agenda item 8 thankfully this is not me
this is councilor organ so without
further ado councilor organ please take
us through the paper Thank You chairman
this report covers the first five months
of the year 2018 19 and the period ends
on the 31st of August the total capital
budget for the year is just a little
over six million pounds and it's
itemized in Para one three capital
funding and progress on expenditure is
detailed in Appendix 1 and section 106
funds held by the council but not yet
committed to projects is detailed in
x2 which is this one back the
recommendation is that the position on
capital expenditure is received Thank
You chairman any questions or comments
mr. Buckland Thank You chairman
I just like to correct an immaculate see
in the report if I may on page 49 where
we have the the financing of the peple
program the note which is shown next to
the figure of a million than 90,000
pounds suggests that this is income
generated from SIL it's not the income
here is revenue contribution to capital
that you approved as a council back in
back in April so apologies for the
accuracy of that no we'll conquer that
mended and you further questions or
comments in that case members of cabinet
the recommendation is the position on
capital X Finn
oh sorry I will try again so the
recommendation on put page 47 position
on capital expenditure and income for
period 1 to 5 of 20 1819 is received and
any issues identified for further
consideration is the recommendation
acceptable thank you so we now are
issues arising from overview and
scrutiny I believe we've dealt with the
main issue arriving from overview and
scrutiny so in that case on block items
so those are dealt with so the cabinet
work program which was to follow thank
you
so the cabinet work program for the
period November 2018 is for noting so we
have melted the cabinet work program
strategic policy advisory group to
receive the minutes of the strategic
policy Advisory Group which are attached
as item 10 page 59 so those are
acceptable as you agreed and any urgent
business or do business in that case I
declare cabinet concluded